I never knew that I needed Katherine
Newberry in my life but I want her to be
real and I want to watch her show every
night this happen like I love this
character so much in this whole story is
this something that you really
gravitated towards when you read the
script and did you write this group of
em I mind I did write the script with
Emma hence my gravity yeah okay yeah we
got to make it we've got to make it and
it's just such a gift I mean the part
but also everything everything in the
script Mindy's character all the all of
the characters in the script I loved
because the writing is all so sharp and
good and everyone speaks with their own
voice it's so authentic it's so funny
it's so witty and trenchant and biting
and I think also very hopeful do you
tell Emma that this is what you're gonna
do and write it or do you write it and
I'd say here you go
I wish I had the relationship with her
that I could have said I'm doing this
you're gonna do it no I didn't know her
so I was just in LA working on my show
and started writing this movie for a
woman I'd never met but was just a fan
of pretty creepy
pretty weird not unlike the movie the
king of comedy but it was I just wrote
it for her and then I sent her the
script through my agency on on the
Friday of Labor Day and I heard back
from her on Sunday yeah there's that
instant Oh instant yeah one of the best
scripts I'd read in years I said this is
it incredibly funny and brilliant I'd
love to do it
have either of you especially after this
experience ever thought about getting
into a talk show or a late-night talk
show could you ever imagine yourselves
doing them because we don't watch either
of you it's really nice of you to say
that but I don't think I could manage it
I mean I'm not a late-night person I'm a
morning person which is why I make films
and rather than do theater um I just
can't get my dander up at night you know
about 11:30 I'm I've been asleep for
about two hours there's a tiny bit of
drool here Oh No
someone's had to come in take the book
wipe my face and turn the light off I
just don't think I'm the right candidate
I would like to wear outfits every day I
would like the fashion element of it or
do you know the way that Mitchell
Travers dressed her in the movie she was
fantastic so I would love the fashion
element of it I wouldn't like the having
to ask celebrities question but then I'm
thinking this is what you do every
single day so you look like your job and
so maybe maybe it would be fun I have to
ask about being that I'm Canadian about
Lily saying we're so excited that she's
hosting late-night talk show first woman
on a major Network show in like 30 years
what are your thoughts what how excited
are you for this both of you I saw the
other day yeah today program in America
and I saw little pieces of her media I'm
very ignorant watch anything because I'm
still read and and there she was from
young doing all this amazing sort of
stuff I think it's so exciting that
someone can come through doing stuff on
their phone and then move into I think
that's very hopeful because certainly in
my country we've got drama schools that
are very difficult for people to get
into from um backgrounds where there's
less very little money and that's not
doing our acting profession any good at
all because you know the gene tools just
getting smaller and smaller um so I
don't know for you it's different but I
think it's I think it's so exciting that
someone who made their own career
themselves through she dances she does
characters impressions she does
everything she did things to that made
her excited and entertained and her
friends and then just got bigger and
bigger and bigger and now that she's
doing this job of national skill I
actually was saying I thought it might
be easier for her to do the show than it
was to do her own YouTube channel show
because in here she doesn't have to do
you know personas she gets to be herself
I really excited to see what she does
with it and obviously as an Indian woman
it's thrilling I
I feel that she is my little daughter or
niece then I feel very proud of her I
know I've actually never met her and I
feel proud of her like I'm like this is
really exciting and lasting and there's
a lot of buzz going around with you
teaming up with Priyanka Chopra very
exciting for the wedding inspired I
guess you would say comedy yes wedding
comedy are you taking inspiration from
her wedding it's hard not to you saw
photos of her her wedding I mean what in
a as a person who isn't married I
thought you know what she's now that
wedding was enough for for 10 or 20
people
that was a good such a beautiful and big
extravagant wedding no it's been great
we're just starting on that so I I don't
have much to announce yet about it but
we've been working on that and I saw her
and can and our lives are so different
it's just nice to it's it's nice to be
working with a woman who is technically
from the same region I am but yet we're
so with such different experiences in
life and she's great
you